as George Orwell once noted the worst
advertisement for socialism is its
adherence according to oral well the
typical socialist is quote either a
youthful snob Bolshevik or more
typically a prim little man with the
white-collar job usually a secret
teetotaler and often with vegetarian
leanings Orwell wrote those words in
1937 but they're weirdly recognizable
today especially the line about
vegetarianism there's something about
the left you may have noticed that makes
them highly neurotic about food it's
been that way for generations but
there's ample evidence the impulse is
getting worse here's a clip from the
other night on CNN Democratic candidates
lining up to denounce meat as immoral
but what you support changing the
dietary guidelines yes you know the food
pyramid yes a reduce red meat
specifically yes I would it's good for
the environment it's good for your
health if you eat less meat certainly
meat is an extraordinarily expensive
thing to produce look there are a lot of
ways that we try to change our energy
consumption some of it is with light
bulbs some of it is on straws some of it
dang is on cheese burgers right catch
that Elizabeth Warren says you eat too
many cheeseburgers as if it's any of her
business but that's the thing she
actually thinks it is her business they
all think that the activists left seeks
to control everything you do including
what you put in your mouth for the last
few years they've been pushing you to
eat bugs bugs remember the headline from
the Washington Post
eating bugs can help the environment or
how about this one from the New York
Times why are we eating more insects
it's bizarre why would they want you to
eat insects because eating insects is
repulsive and unamerican
and of course therefore in the eyes of
the left it must be awesome the more
perverse and unnatural the better that
has always been their standard they're
not leading a political movement by the
way they're leading a revolt against
their fathers but given that we
shouldn't be surprised by what happened
on Swedish television this week when a
researcher called Magnus soderlund
unveiled his plan to fight climate
change
according to soderlund eating insects is
not enough cutting greenhouse gas
emissions may require us to develop a
taste for human flesh
yes it's time to practice eco
cannibalism watch a census taken once
time to test me I ate his liver with
some fava beans and a nice Chianti sorry
wrong wrong clip what you get the point
professor so Dolan went on to say that
unfortunately many people might bulk at
cannibalism they're just too uptight and
middle-class to eat human flesh so he
suggested baby steps to open their minds
to it start by eating their own pets
have a cocker spaniel burger for the
planet now the Swedes we should tell you
are several years ahead of us here in
the US in their climate consciousness
but we'll get there soon and when we do
get there it will be due to the tireless
evangelizing of eco prophets like Saint
Pete Buddha judge of South Bend is put a
judge noted the other night God Himself
strongly agrees with every word that st.
Pete utters you know if you believe that
God is watching as poison is being
belched into the air of creation and
people are being harmed by it countries
are at risk of vanishing in low-lying
areas we suppose God thinks of that I
bet he thinks it's messed up at least
one way of talking about this is that
it's a kind of sin here that disagreeing
with st. Pete is a sin or as
Episcopalians like Saint Pete put it a
kind of sin whatever it's bad what
apparently is not a sin is flying on
private jets which Saint Pete does more
than any other Democratic candidate in
the race of course if you did it if you
wind up within 50 feet of a charter jet
the left would denounce you as a
heartless plutocrat who's murdering the
planet but when they fly private is very
different very different it's necessary
it's not frivolous
they have to it's virtuous actually so
there are two standards one for them one
for everyone else they're like that
everything by the
watch for example as st. Pete needles
the rest of us proles about our naughty
plastic straw habit I think we're
thinking about it mostly through the
perspective of guilt you know from using
a straw to eating a burger am i part of
the problem and in a certain way yes but
the most exciting thing is that we can
all be part of the solution you desert
it when you use a drinking straw says
st. Pete of South Bend you're part of
the problem unless you happen to be Pete
Buddha judge himself and you find
yourself at the Iowa State Fair in which
case you can eat all the meat you want
and yes you can drink from a plastic
straw watch and there's no long term
plan well there's one on one do they
want to know about policy or do they
want it and how do you pitch something
like a plan for how do you demonstrate
to people here that you could be the guy
you starting to figure this out
straws for me but not for thee don't
like it tough stop your whining and eat
your insects or your pets or your
neighbors we're heading out for a
cheeseburger